that stops I could have saved your life
a 19 year old dies in a crash now her
mother speaking out devastated and left
to care for the young woman's child
police report 19-year-old Zara Ochoa
died in last night's crash riding in the
passenger seat of a car that apparently
blew through a stop sign this unfolding
on North 5th Street and San Miguel
Avenue up in North Las Vegas and we're
told the driver was a family member with
no driver's license good evening to you
I'm Brian Loftus and I'm Denise Valdez
so tonight Zara's mother is speaking out
sharing some memories of her teenage
daughter and how there is an important
message for all of us in our community
Christian casares has the story
all right you do run this top twice this
is why why a series of questions that
Teresa Garcia says she can't find the
answers to after she learned that her 19
year old daughter Sarah Cardenas was
killed Sunday night she says Sarah was a
young mother who loved music and wanted
to be a nurse last time I talked to her
um was Sunday afternoon according to
North Las Vegas Police about 11 30 the
Honda Cardenas was a passenger and was
traveling East on San Miguel approaching
North fifth that's just south of Craig
Road the driver of the Honda ran the
stop sign and was T-boned by a Jeep
traveling north on North 5th Street
Garcia says a relative arrived to the
area and was able to exchange a few
words with Cardenas my daughter was in
the car and saying I can't breathe I
can't breathe
so I guess she panicked I'm just numb
North Las Vegas Police say the Honda
driver was 16 and unlicensed got it
announced was taken to UMC where she
passed away I always told her I might be
a regular start driving get your
driver's license I've been in many car
accidents I was even pregnant with her
when I was in my last car accident
Garcia says the 16 year old is Cardenas
sister-in-law she suffered minor
injuries all you had to do was just stop
and wait for your turn it's not that
rush to get home you live five minutes
away from where you were at
it could have waited
North Las Vegas Police telling eight
news now they will submit charges to the
D.A on the 16 year old driver for a
vehicular manslaughter no driver's
license and failing to yield from a stop
sign